our third last but not the least speaker
for today
uh is suzanna sedan
i'm saying it right sudan is now
uh in the institute of mathematics at
czech academy of sciences
but before i think you were at kth and
in toronto and probably in some other
places
working with a lot of uh people in the
community and contributing to
a huge number of recent really cool
results
including uh the one uh i guess you're
going to talk about the
non uh automatability results so so far
we've seen
lower bounds for proof size existence of
proof
but suzanne will tell us how to
actually prove something very cool about
proof search
please go ahead okay uh thank you
antonina thanks for
the organizers for inviting me um
yes so i'll be talking about
non-automatability
and so the motivation to study
non-automatability is
the question how hard is it to find
proofs
right so we know yes that's all
versified proofs of unsatisfiability
formulas with thousands of variables
but we know that the search space of
proofs is very large
so so
how do they do this how um how hard is
this problem actually
and uh well at least we know that there
is
a proof of size 2 to the n which is easy
to find
and that would be just checking all the
possible
assignments and and seeing if any of
them are
satisfied with the formula
and and one way to lower bound the time
that sat solvers take is by proving a
lower bound
in the size of the proof that they
generate
but a natural question is can sat
solvers
actually find these small proofs if they
exist
or are these two measures at least
polynomially related
and and this is uh what gives the
motivation for the definition of
automatability
so we say a proof system p is
automatable in time
f of n if there exists an algorithm a
deterministic algorithm
that given an unsatisfiable formula
outputs a p refutation of this formula
in time f of n and
and here this n is the the size
of the smallest p refutation of f plus
the size of f
so we need to give the algorithm time to
read the input
so we need to give it the time uh
proportional to the size of f
but also to produce the output and it
has to produce a
p refutation so that's why we take
size of the smallest purification plus
the size of f
and and if we just say that
that p is automatable we mean
automatable in polynomial time
okay so
so this is the concept we'll be talking
about in this talk so can we find
uh small proofs if they exist
and i will start by giving some
non-trivial
non-trivial automatability algorithms
and then i'll talk about
the non-automatability results
so first let's see the positive results
automating algorithms um so
just uh some quick um
yeah definitions to make sure we're uh
yeah on the same page so i'll be talking
about resolution
uh if unless i state otherwise
we'll think of formulas with constant
width
and uh i'll be talking about tree-like
resolution when the
when the proof uh is a tree
and uh and i'll at some point also
mention regular resolution so
that's just if we consider any path in
this
proof tag from um from the uh
source to the sink then i resolve on a
given variable at
any given variable at most once
uh and i'll also be talking about these
measures that
robert was talking about too so the
proof size
and the proof width uh and i'll also use
this perspective he talked about like
that you can see a resolution proof as a
query model solving this falsified
clause search problem
okay um so
so the first uh automatable automatic
ability algorithm is for tree-like
resolution
so this was uh um
yeah shown by being potassi
and actually they observed this it's a
simple algorithm that they
uh have in this paper
and it's actually it's automatable in
time
n to the log s so we can actually even
like separate the size of the formula
from the size of the smallest
refutation so let me present you this
algorithm because i think it's very
it's it's very nice and uh simple so
so we're given this unsatisfiable cnf
formula
and suppose that we know the size of the
smallest
tree-like refutation if
if we don't we can just try this
algorithm for s equals one equals two
until it actually
produces a a reputation
so suppose this is known and and now
it's a simple observation that uh there
exists some some variable
that if i if i restrict the formula by
this variable
uh either by this variable set to zero
or by this variable set to one at least
one of these
will have the size less than s over two
and that's very easy to see if we just
consider uh a tree like
refutation there is one last variable to
be resolved on
and if we just uh and at least one of
the sides
of this tree has to be of size less than
s over two so this is
the only observation needed and then uh
the
the idea is that you'll first try to
find
uh what variable and what polarity
um we we have to set to to find the
proof of size s over two so that's this
two times
n here so we'll try all the n variables
and
all the two possible polarities and
and then try to find uh a proof of size
s over two
and once this is found then i i can
recurse
um on the other side with one less less
variable
so this gives the automating algorithm
and time end to the log
s okay
so so this is uh for tree-like
resolution so
what about for resolution can we do
anything better than just
two to the n um
and and this follows from uh benzesson
and victor said
so we can actually beat the
this um two to the n algorithm so
if if you think of this as uh s being
polynomial in n
then this this algorithm is uh basically
2 to the square root n so so if we have
polynomial size proofs then we can find
proofs in time
less than the trivial two to the end
and this just follows from um the
the the fact that we can automate
with so so consider this algorithm so
we'll
uh we'll start with w equals one two
and increasing and we'll always derive
uh
all the all the at most end to the w
clauses derivable and with w
so i just keep increasing the number of
clauses i can derive
and this can be done in time enter the o
of w
um and at some point
i will be able to derive contradiction
so and and the point i'll be able to
derive contradiction is when w
is the minimum with required to derive
contradiction
uh and what benzes and invictus and
showed was that
uh if f can be refuted in size s then f
can be refuted in with at most
square root of n log s
so putting these two things together we
get the that resolution is automatable
in in this time
okay so so we can do better than
trivial for for resolution um
so yeah what other automatability
algorithms do we have um well for
algebraic proof systems we already
heard a bit about these proof systems um
so i
i won't be defining them but just um
they work with polynomials that's all we
need to know
for now so
right so we saw that resolution this
automatability algorithm follows from
this width automatability algorithm
and for these algebraic semi algebraic
proof systems we also have a similar
degree automatability and
and we also have a very similar size
degree relation for
polynomial calculus and also for
surely atoms and sum of squares so this
gives also
some non-trivial automatability
algorithm for
for sum of squares charlie atoms and
polynomial calculus
interestingly we don't for new student
sets
i i don't know of any non-trivial
in terms of size automatability
algorithm in terms of size we have
in terms of degree but um but we don't
have the size degree relation
so it's actually not true for the
student sets so
so anyway so the this is as far as i
know
all the um yeah automatability
well yeah algorithms that that we have
and now for some non-automatability
results
uh so first i'd like to uh
talk about what the non-auto beta
automatability world looked like before
this
breakthrough result of observies mullet
um
so so the first um
result was this non-automatability of
extended freight
and with the condition that unless
rsa can be broken by polynomial size
circuits
this was proved in already in 98
by crycek at pudlock
so this was actually so they talk about
feasible interpolation in the paper
and but it follows because
automatability implies
uh feasible interpolation
but okay so there's this cryptographic
assumption that gives not
automated automatability of uh
extended fraying then this was
uh strengthened to um
other also strong proof systems um
so again we have some cryptographic
assumption
and we can also show that
even tc0 fregae is uh
non-automatable unless this
this diffie-hellman procedure can be
broken by polynomial size circuits
and for ac 0 frequency we need
a stronger assumption we need
sub-exponential size circuits
okay so this is non-automatability
results for
the strong proof systems um
you could say that it's kind of expected
that
strong proof systems are harder to to
automate um and simpler systems
should be easy but okay maybe this is
more of an
intuition um
and uh okay so the first um
result for weaker proof systems was uh
this
election of big res brof result which
where they showed that resolution and
tree-like resolutions are not
automatable in polynomial time unless
uh this hierarchy
in in parameter parameterized complexity
uh collapses to fpt
so um so yeah so this was
uh it's it's a nice paper but it's a
complicated proof
um and uh
so this was the first non-automatability
result for resolution
this was later extended to polynomial
calculus and nostellian sets
and also a more recent result was
uh able to prove not only
non-automatability and polynomial time
but a
bit larger than polynomial time for both
resolution and tree-like resolution
with a slightly stronger assumption that
yeah it each is false
so so this was uh before
this i'd say yes muller so then
we have uh just two years ago
this uh this results that uh from
city as well that showed that resolution
is np hard to
automate and um
and after this there were several
follow-up results um extending
extending this to other proof systems so
we have this uh
np hardness of automating cutting planes
uh also and the hardness of automating
risk k
for small values of k and then this
uh np hardness of
automating algebraic proof systems and
even some hardness of
automating tree-like resolution uh
in time better than that autumn
automating algorithm that we saw so and
the little low of login so these were
all follow-ups to
to the ateria's mole
so so now i'd like to talk more about
the ateria's mullet
uh technique yeah how it was done and
then
how these well some of these general
generalizations came up
um so by the way are there any questions
so far i think i'm
like speaking quickly i don't know if i
there any questions up to this point
when you say eth hard to automate you
mean uh
under the assumption that eth is
uh yeah it's not possible to automate
unless ethers falls
yes exactly that's what i mean yes
yes
can you go back to that parameters
complexity result that you mentioned
oh yes
and i i had a more general question
which was
um has there been any attempt to think
about
well a proof system may not be
automatable under uh for
for arbitrary formulas uh or um
but maybe automatable under some
parameterization
you see what i mean like if you were to
restrict the class of formulas
and say okay for this restricted class
of formulas say i do have a polynomial
proof
can i find it
i think that's a great question and i
think yeah um
i don't know of any results
um i mean there are these results about
like for example when you have a small
tree width or um
i'm not sure i'm not very familiar with
the
with these results like when
so if you have small tree with there
there are
um in some some graph
uh representation of the formula there
are um
small proofs and i think you can even
find them
um but i'm not i'm not completely sure
but i think it's very it's an
interesting question because um yeah
there might be formulas for which
a class general class of formulas for
which it's uh we can actually find
proofs
so so yeah i don't know if other people
wanted some messages ryan williams is
if the refutation width might be
parameterized
parameterizable ryan says there is also
work by zoe bell on
ecc see
right right so this uh so zoe bell yes
uh
so the the so that work it it shows
uh that it even works for subsystems of
resolution so even regular ordered
resolution
but you also have uh
np hardness of automating
uh and jakob said yeah refutation width
might be a parameterization
um yeah if you consider
constant width then yeah then you can
find in polynomial time
all right that's the result by aft 21
okay
for bonded with formless i think you can
find proofs in
yeah that's the the algorithm
i'm not sure if that's in the but it's
it's the algorithm of simply trying to
generate all possible
uh clauses that you can in in a certain
way
what let's see if there's any oh russell
has a question what about weak
automatizability
where if a tautology has a proof in one
system you find a proof in a larger
system okay
okay right so that's a good question so
so some of these so for the
non-automatability results for the
strong proof systems i talked about
these are actually
weak automatability results so this
means that
um so tc0 frequent
is not not even weakly automatable so
that means that you cannot
uh even if you're allowed to find proofs
and stronger proof systems
uh you can't do it in in polynomial time
on the
smallest tc0 frequent uh proof system
uh for for these other
for the weaker proof systems
we don't have any um
weak non-weak automatability results um
i guess the best we have is is that
the let's say for example here uh
so we have that uh even if you're
allowed
to to output uh polynomial calculus or
shirley atoms or cutting
planes uh refutations you can't automate
resolution
so so you can go only up to
to these uh proof systems for which we
we know
non-automatability results
um yeah
but i think yeah that's that's the one
of the
main open questions is can can we prove
um that resolution is not weakly
automatable
there's another question
results based on others will also
give the weak automatability
i'm not sure what dimitri means
dimitri duantes
results based
so i i think the uh the i think you
already said what dimitri was
was was saying basically so even if you
had something
that had and um you you can't tell
whether it has
an efficient even you know say regular
ordered resolution
and figured out a good proof in cutting
planes like you can't
right that or or or these other top
level proof systems
right so there's there's hardness for
for that stretch all the way from just
above tree-like resolution
all the way up to the top systems you've
got here and i think you already said it
right okay yes yes that makes sense
yes
signing yes yes and continue please
okay perfect all right so now i'll go
into uh a bit about
how these results are proved um
so so this is uh atiya's mullet um
so um they showed that if resolution is
automatable in polynomial time then
uh np is in p if it's automatable in
quasi polynomial of time then then p is
in qp
and if it's automated one
sub-exponential that's
uh two to the end the little low of 1
then it's n p is in sub-exponential time
okay so in order to show this the main
theorem
is that so if you're given sienna
formula
f there's this algorithm that
outputs a cnf formula a of f
in polynomial time such that if
if f is satisfiable then aff
has small resolution refutations
and if f is unsatisfiable then aff
requires
very large exponential size resolution
refutations
okay so this this is the main theorem um
and and from this uh the
non-automatability result follows
uh directly so let me just uh
show why but this is uh
implication so so suppose we have an
algorithm that
automates resolution in in some time f
of n so you think of f either
polynomial quasi-polynomial or
sub-exponential
um so now we want to decide
whether uh f is
satisfiable or unsatisfiable uh
in the same amount of
time so either if f is polynomial we'll
still be doing
it in polynomial time or
quasi-polynomial sub-exponential
and and what we do is simply run this
this algorithm on this formula a of f
for uh this amount of time so here s
is the upper bound in the case where f
is satisfiable
we know that there's a resolution uh
refutation of size s
and t is the the time this
algorithm takes so we know that the size
of the of the formula is at most t
because it's outputting this formula so
we just run it for this amount of time
and s plus t is
uh is polynomial so we know that
if f is satisfiable then since
this algorithm is actually
it automates resolution in in time f of
n
we know that it will return a refutation
so if f is satisfiable then
then it will return some refutation
and the other direction also holds so if
a returns a reputation then we know f is
satisfiable
and this is because
this this is true if if this f
of s plus t is less than
the required size of
resolution refutations if f is unsat
so whenever if f is any of these
functions polynomial quasi-polynomial
sub-exponential
then this will be true so then we'll
have that
if the algorithm returns a refutation we
know that f is satisfiable so we're
solving
uh a np heart problem in time uh
f of n okay
so so um the non-automatability
result boils down to proving an upper
bound and a lower bound
constructing this formula af and proving
an upper bound and a lower bound
depending on whether f is satisfiable
okay so now i'll first
uh just explain what this
wait let me see how i'm going on time uh
how
how much time do i have anthony now um
that's okay you could still take
i don't know 10 minutes okay
all right so i think that's enough time
okay so i first want to explain what
this
what this uh formula is that that this
algorithm outputs and then i'll give a
sketch of how the upper bound and lower
bounds
are are shown uh also for the
generalizations which is
similar okay so so the formula
is this ref formula and it's encoding
that f has
a short resolution refutation so size s
think of it as some polynomial we'll
define define it later
so so this formula it's uh you can think
of it as
it has some some blocks here i put the
blocks in a certain structure but just
think that
okay they're blocks which uh are
supposed to represent
the clauses of this refutation
and uh so we have a total of s blocks
and for each block we'll have a set of
variables
so we'll have two n variables
to indicate what clause is represented
in that block
uh so yeah one per possible literal
uh and we'll have an axiom saying that
well the
there's a special block in this in this
ref formula that has to have
the empty clause so that this is
actually a refutation
okay then
uh we have uh two times log
s variables and this is going to
represent
pointers uh
to two so the
internal or derived blocks in this
formula
they'll have two pointers to the
uh clauses that are used to derive it
so this is going to be these two times
log s
variable so here i have the encoding in
binary
uh and also uh
login uh variables to indicate
what is the variable that's being
resolved over
okay so let me just point out that this
differs a little bit from
what the formula that ad series mullet
has because here i'm using
uh binary encoding and this simplifies
the
proof of the lower bound a bit so
uh okay but the idea is the same
um okay and then i need to have some
some uh clauses in ref that say that
this is actually a valid resolution step
so that that means that uh this
this uh this is actually of the form
c or uh x d are not x and then i'm
actually producing something in the form
c or t
okay so so we'll have some clauses
that that actually
enforce this and then
finally so at the
the sources the ones that are not
derived blocks
they have to come from some axiom of the
formula
f so they have to be a a weakening of
some
some axiom
so then that's that we also have these
these causes encoding this
so so this is the the ref formula so i
really want to
to write that um in code that
f has a resolution refutation of size s
so that's what this ref formula is is
saying
okay
so so just uh so this formula
it will have about s times n variables
um and for this it's important that i
use the
this binary encoding
and and it has some polynomial number of
clauses of with
o of log n because s is polynomial in n
so it's just
it's not constant with but it's still
small width
okay how do you say that
short the relation short how do you say
it's
short ah that's just because the
the i only have s blocks here
so so the the refutation has to fit into
these s
blocks so that's that's how
uh yeah it's it's restricted to these as
blocks
okay okay so this is the the
ref formula and now
uh so let's see the the upper bound
um for uh for the upper bound
here it's it's useful to think of this
falsified clause search problem
um and and
here the the natural proof we we get is
um would correspond to read one's
branching program
which corresponds to regular resolution
so
so the idea is that we'll fix some
satisfying assignment
for for f and then uh
we start at at the block which we know
is the empty clause and we
will keep this invariant that the our
satisfying assignment that that we fix
falsifies the clause in the current
block so it's definitely true when we
start
in the when we have the empty clause
and and since these are all these should
all be valid
uh resolution steps we can always find
one direction in which this
this invariant will still be true
so the idea is that we we follow this
path
and we'll either detect a non-valid
derivation step
or we'll be able to follow this path
until we reach
some some block which is uh
actually a sink so it's it's has a
pointer to
to some axiom of f
and uh but since this is a satisfying
assignment
uh it's it cannot um
falsify a weakening of an axiom of f
because it satisfies all the axioms of f
so then we also found
uh um some falsified clause of ref so
ref cannot be a refutation
cannot be encoding a refutation of f so
what's the size of this
uh of this proof of this upper bound
so it's it's basically you can do this
in
uh the number of blocks squared um
so this is because if you think of what
the
uh branching program has to remember
at each step it it has to only remember
the current block it's in
and uh and the uh and the next block
it's going to
so so that's why you get uh
number of blocks squared and number of
blocks is is going to be polynomial so
we'll get some polynomial upper bound
okay
okay so this this is the the upper bound
and and for the lower bounds well
um so what i'd serious mullet show they
show this with
lower bound for for this ref formula
and uh with lower bound of s over n
okay so from from this we can use the
the pencils on victorson uh
size with relation and okay so let's
remember so we have ref has
s times n variables they have with log n
so if we just
apply this we get that
resolution refutation of size
exponential in
s over n cubed
so if as long as we choose s large
enough we'll get an
uh lower bound of two to the omega
okay so this is not what azerias muller
do in their
in their paper because they don't use
the this binary encoding they use a
unary encoding
so what they actually do has has to do
with what robert was talking about
earlier
so uh consider a lifted version which
they call um
okay you can consider it as a lifting
technique they
it's a this relativization technique so
it's very similar
um and and from that so if you consider
the the lifted version of this formula
ref f
then you can show that actually this
this width lower bound
actually becomes a size lower bound
okay and and you even get better
parameters here so you don't need to
choose uh as so big you can choose s
like n squared
okay and then just uh one observation so
if if we do use lifting we also have to
show that
this lifting preserves the upper bound
so
lift ref also has to be easy when f
is satisfiable
okay so so let's see how this uh the the
how the extensions um are are shown
so the upper bound for for
uh most of these uh follow from the
upper bound for resolution
so how is the lower bound shown um
so so actually so this um
yeah i didn't say before so actually uh
what i'd say is move this show they show
actually
a block with lower bounds so here
we think of the variables as partitioned
in two blocks
so this is actually the natural
partition
uh that you get thinking of the those
blocks i had talked about before
and and the block width is just the
number of blocks
a clause touches okay so
uh so they actually show that the block
width is large
uh and then so then you can apply this
lifting and and it's actually
it's a block lifting um
uh and this is important to preserve the
upper bound
so uh so this block lifting then you can
show that
this requires a resolution size
exponential and
s over n then uh
so for the cutting planes uh what gkmp
did
was uh on this other lifting theorem
that
yeah robert also talked about where
we're composing with the indexing
gadgets
um except that they need also a
blockwise version
uh of that so they need it's also
multiplayer kind of lifting but so they
proved this lifting theorem and then
they can get
the cutting planes lower about um what
garlic does also is
uh uh well he calls it a the
relativization k-fold relativization
technique but also it's this
also a lifting uh and could get the size
lower bound for
for res k in this algebraic
uh paper it's also showing that
this lifting can give you a polynomial
calculus charlie adams uh
size lower bound and um
and here just us yeah small observation
that
so actually what what this last paper uh
was also doing is showing that uh
this block with lower bounds could act
can actually
also be shown by a reduction to
pigeonhole principle
and uh yeah you you get a
slightly weaker lower bound but uh it's
it's
like modular you can directly reduce the
pigeonhole principle and then get the
lower bound from pigeonhole principle
and
uh and the same holds for the block
degree
so um since pigeonhole principle is hard
for
both uh degree wise for both polynomial
calculus and charlie adams
that's how we can get the degree lower
bound um
for these proof systems and
uh so yeah so so this
um also might ex
explain why well it explains why this
this technique of reducing
did not give something for sos because
sos has
small degree uh refutations of uh
pigeonhole principle
and uh just one picture
about uh so so the idea is that
we want to show that the degree required
uh for ref uh has to be
larger than the degree required for
pigeonhole principle
um perhaps i yeah i wasn't planning on
going into this but just
showing the picture that you know this
these things are somewhat related
so here we have these pointers um
these children pointers that um
uh have to go to blocks but we don't
have enough blocks so
um you can actually make this formal end
and and show a reduction okay
so um right so
um so this is there a question
yes yes yes i'll be done soon uh
okay so um
right so i explained how to get uh the
upper bounds
um so the lower bounds so for for the
upper bounds uh
so for new student sets you actually
have to
change the formula a bit in order it
doesn't come from resolution because it
doesn't simulate resolution
um from the risk k you also have to
prove a lower
upper bound which i think only holds for
res
two i'm not mistaken uh it's not doesn't
come directly
uh from resolution uh and for and
clearly for the tree-like resolution you
you also you have to change the formula
uh
the upper bounds does not come from
resolution so you need another formula
okay so just to yeah wrap up
uh okay so we talked about some
automatability results for
tree-like resolution and then also some
that come from
degree or with automatability plus this
size degree or size with relation
and then the non-automatability results
that can be
basically
split into two types so for strong proof
systems under these
crypto assumptions and then for weak
proof systems
p not equal to p and then i think there
are
many like very nice open problems here
so
of course we can think about um yeah can
we generalize this to
these other proof systems for which
proof systems are which we can prove
lower bounds
um so sos bonded the fragi i mean for
bound to death freaky
yeah can we um
get non-automatic ability under some
some other assumption um
and uh yeah um res k for larger values
of k
or or this resolution over polynomial
calculus of degree d defined by
in credit check so
so i think uh these are our natural
questions also
since it seems like yeah weaker proof
systems are
uh more uh malleable to uh
automatization uh so
what about yeah what if we consider
other tree-like proof systems
uh are these um can we show
some non-automatability results here uh
so
yeah something is known for tree like
cutting planes but
it's not optimal
also we talked about weak automatability
so there
yeah it's a important open problem
and um yeah uh recently i also uh heard
jan krajczek also talking about uh other
can we formalize uh
what is the optimal way to search for
proofs so he has uh
an information efficiency function which
actually is is
characterizes what what you can
uh the time required to to find
uh proofs so so i think there's yeah
also a lot of
interesting things that that um
you can work on because um yeah that
that was the inspiration for
automatability we want to search for
proof so
yeah so that's it okay thanks
thank you very much questions comments
there are a number of questions
throughout the talk but
more questions and comments
okay if you don't mind me ask question
so i was wondering
if there is any um anything about
optimal proof systems and automatability
of
an automatability of optimal prox
systems so if there exists an optimal
probe system
is it supposed to be not automatizable
automatically how would that
um okay so
um one thing is that these
um the results for
um uh under crypto assumptions
these were uh results that were
non-weekly automatable so we know that
anything that simulates these are not
automatable
um
but i perhaps more can be said about
this i don't know if someone
in the audience wants to also say
something
uh i know so so when kryczek was was
talking about this he
also had some connection between uh
this um
optimality of proof search and
optimal proof systems so
so yeah i think there are other
connections
thank you so there is another question
in the chat
so might it be correct to say
automatability is related to a kind
of another width size trade-off
it's related
not exactly sure what you mean here
so the positive results of
automatability they are related to these
um size width size degree tradeoffs
uh
[Music]
so what about the following variant of
the question so there are
those give the upper bounds how far are
the
np hardness uh from those upper bounds
like how much
could we pretend you know what's the gap
between
uh the the best we know out of
the uh degree of you know width or
degree automatize
automatability and the lower bounds the
np hardness lower bounds that are
implied
right right uh right so you don't
you don't you can't get that these are
optimal like you can't get the bet
system vectors and
is optimal so i think what you get
is some that that you do have some
polynomial dependency
on n in the exponent so
but you don't get that square root n is
the optimal um
under under any assumption yeah you
can't get up to that
um so so yeah so that's also interesting
can you actually show that pencils and
pictures and
or these size degree relations are are
actually optimal under
under some strong assumption well but
for t like you did prove that the three
like optima
oh yes yes for for tree-like resolution
under eth so we're using the strong
assumption
then um uh then
that algorithm is really optimal
okay more questions comments by the way
you're going to speak at another
wardrobe
on march 25 is that right yes
yes then the third day workshop
the thursday workshop exactly
yes so just kind of
advertisement for your next talk thanks
okay um so thank you very very much i
guess
nobody seems to be raising hands at the
moment
thank you very very much this was really
really cool and
thank all the speakers this was
fantastic